you're probably wondering by the title
of this video to see what is the most
expensive thing at Starbucks I'm sure
that's probably the way else there might
be more expensive but I haven't found it
and for me personally this is the most
expensive thing that I've ever bought it
Starbucks and let me tell you what was
it worth it
yes he doesn't one and yes it is worth
it this thing has brought me so much joy
over the past couple of weeks that I've
had it and it's been really difficult
for me to keep this a secret because
it's the newly thing but I wanted to
talk about I'm going to show what you
want wanted to post on Instagram of
wonderful gem snapchat I want even both
of on Facebook but I have it because
I've been saving it through this very
video people have been to my house is
like do not talk about the big cut we
cannot address the elephant in the room
which is not actually an elephant we
cannot address the fact that I've got
this sitting in my kitchen it's just for
that so now everybody who wanted to take
a picture and post this before come back
over even post it now we want to talk
about the story of why I purchased it
it's quite a silly reason actually
mostly because I didn't even think of
this was something that I could purchase
because every time I'm at a store and I
see something really cool like this
there was a huge Lego minifigure that I
saw in the store and I asked to buy it
and the guy was like well that's not for
sale boy Oh Monty it's clearly on
display to be purchased and I'm willing
to give you the money for the idol we
have it how does minifigure were so cool
but I still think about it anyway
that's cute the big Cup at hand I was
basically having like the worst week
ever I shattered my phone so many things
had gone wrong in this week is that I
was just like so while my phone is
getting fixed at the Apple store I went
to Starbucks and it's all this up there
on the display like that sitting up on
the shelf very very high order my drink
and I'm like yo this ain't for sale he's
like well nobody's ever really asking me
that so I don't think so I mean I guess
blue why not I mean if it's on the shelf
usually we sell everything on the
shelves they asked me to
the bottom if there's a SKU number than
yeah it was in fact for sale why sports
it over I see 94 95 and I'm like why
ridiculous absolute waste of money
I need it I had so many plans just go
through my mind what I was going to do
with it I'm going to walk around outside
and pick it up with one hand
unfortunately Matt was able to pick it
up with one hand but I can't I can't
hold it straight laughter I make all
facility videos I'm probably going to
put a potted plant in it because it's
basically the most perfect plant pot
ever I'd like to put maybe a tiny tree
like a mini tree in it I don't really
know anything about many trees except
the therm so the guy brings it up and it
turns out it's actually only $73 it was
on sale yep
what yeah okay sure I'll take it
and since my phone was broken and it was
the Apple Store I wasn't logged in on my
Starbucks app so I didn't have my
Starbucks app and I and you look like
whoa I've got two stars for this
purchase said every download two
Starbucks app on my pickle phone and
everything you know long story short
it's all worked out great I got a lot of
a lot of points and a lot of stars
whatever the fact is this cup sits on my
head we disap on my head right now here
are you having quite a substantial cup I
wonder how many cups of coffee we sit in
here does it say how many ounces and
then for decoration only Oh Starbucks
Coffee Company in Seattle manufactured
for Starbucks 2016 all rights reserved
made in China the like look there was a
SKU so he said if there's a skill I
could buy it and after I bought it there
was a huge open spot on that shelf where
this once belong to be having I was like
no one's that are bought it no one's
ever asked to buy it and never they just
usually take pictures of it in the store
so here comes crazy Justine knowing that
this needs to be an item in her life and
it completely just turned that off a
week slide down into a very very happy
day tell you how funny it was I mean
carrying this thing around the street
trying to get it to my car
because I didn't want to go into the
Apple store with it I need so Evie
what was I carrying it like this and I
was walking out of the store trying to
carry this plus my purse and a full hot
peel of like this put so awkward I was
so afraid I was going to drop it
do I think of purchase do you think it
was I think it worth it
I've already got so much joy and so much
entertainment out of it that I think you
before that I can't wait to plant my
plants do I have any suggestions for
plants that I should play it because I
don't know anything about plants or
keeping them alive maybe a cactus I
should definitely definitely plan to
caption because that'll stay alive yeah
that's it that's the end of the story I
just wanted to show you guys my new big
cup and talk about money management and
the dog doesn't really like it
I kept trying to put treats in it and he
would just be like and then run the
other way
well no do I think my cup for me I've
given you funny you things would you
like to see me do with a cup I think
that I would like to fill it up with
coffee and try to drink it
oh that's not safe don't do that that's
a bad idea
we'll see you guys later and hope you
guys have a great day click like if you
like big cups and you can not lie Oh God
I'm here all day I'll see you guys later
haha this is slow Graham so happy so
this is what it looks like I can't even
turn around because I'm in such a tight
space but well how's it look from the
back you look good they both fall out I
mean the good news is oh gosh my guess
the good news is this they fall out
they're both